One of the assays that
we do here in our lab
is called larval turning.
And what we do is we take a
seven-day-old larva that you
see here on this screen.
This is a larva with ALS.
And we can flip it over
using a paintbrush,
and time to see how long this
larva takes to flip over,
belly-side down, and make its
first forward fluid motion.
Flies are a great model system
that have been traditionally
used to study development,
and to identify
genes that are important
for human development,
for human health.
And in the past
several years, they
have been used to
study human diseases.
We can test what happens
here at this protein level
with these small molecules.
And I give it to her, she
can test a small molecule
on her fly, and she can
test it in this ALS model.
And we sort of work on
developing in silico,
on the computer, here is some
protein, do we put-- here
is where we want to target
the small molecule after we've
studied it in my lab of
what's wrong with it,
and here's where we can fix it.
And then once we fix it, we
take it to the next step.
Daniela test it in the fly.
She gives it back to
us, and we sort of
go into this really
wonderful circle.
We have the tools in the fly
model to tweak those changes
and see what would be
the most effective way
to restore neuronal function,
and figure out strategies that
could help motor neuron
survival that can potentially
prolong a patient's life, and
improve the quality of life.